welcome to play today today three women  is gonna cook the birthday  I'm Jean my name is Teresa AKA Freedom  my name  [Music]  is let this boil before I add the  instant mashed potatoes don't tell  nobody so what I'm doing is basically  combining different cultures French  cuisine Creole Cuisine and also a little  twist to California because I got that  Snoop Dogg wine for you put my heart box  solid to this  as I can see the plate is really well  served I think that person is really  generous I am generous I  [Music]  the meat is not cooked enough he doesn't  click in all those memories that I have  about these friends but it's new  memories y'all can make new memories  Coming to America  [Applause]  [Music]